everything's bigger in texas especially
the covid figures the number continues
to grow each and every day huge state
huge surge huge division we will not
comply and my child will be at school
without a mask huge problem houston is
in a real mess hospitals expanding into
tents in parking lots texas bringing two
and a half thousand health workers in
from other states we need those males
numbers here their highest since january
infections through the roof vaccinations
through the floor and schools going back
in a week as a parent do you feel
concerned are you worried about your
kids when they go back yes definitely
yeah definitely i feel like i want to go
to watch to see what's going on this
stadium swapping football for vaccines
for parents kids anyone over the age of
12. how old are you uh 12 so 12 so
you've got your vaccine today yeah how
do you feel about it uh i mean it hurt
but i'm happy because you know like now
i can go to school and i'm not like that
scared of getting covered but i'm still
gonna wear a mask the mayor handing them
out along with books and bags
controversial in itself because the
fight here isn't just against covid it's
also against the state's governor see
greg abbott is refusing to bring a mass
mandate in in fact he's going even
further he is actively suing any school
any business that tells its people
they've got to wear these things a
thousand dollars a time because he says
it should be down to personal choice
whereas here in houston the schools are
saying you know what we're going to tell
kids they have to wear these and we'll
see you in court
are you scared that the schools have
been going to be sued
no i'm not concerned about that
i am concerned about our kids getting
sick and it can be preventable i'm
concerned about teachers and bus drivers
and cafeteria workers and janitors
getting sick and
certainly don't want anybody ending up
in the hospital and dying new infections
are at around 15 and a half thousand a
day in texas right now that is up 34
from last week more than 90 percent of
icu beds are now taken 40 percent of
them down to covid
and the majority of them are
unvaccinated because here in the us's
second most populated state fewer than
half of eligible residents have taken up
the offer of the vaccine and so the
state and the schools squaring up for a
fight of wills against the backdrop of a
pandemic and what would you say to greg
abbott the governor
governor
we love you but get some common sense
phil lavelle al jazeera houston texas